das projekt jamaika kommt nicht vom
fleck gut da müssen wir von der heute
show eben mal hilfestellung leisten wie
man im sportunterricht sagen würde
hazel droge hat in berlin den blutjungen
cdu-abgeordneten sepp müller zum ersten
mal im bundestag mit dem grünen tobias
lindner zusammen gebracht denn zwischen
den parteien gibt es ja den meisten
streit wissen sie und wenn die
störrischen alten keinen
koalitionsvertrag auf die reihe kriegen
muss eben der nachwuchs ran
ich möchte diesen prozess gerne ein
bisschen beschleunigen habe mir daher
ein paar junge politiker der jeweiligen
parteien eingeladen
die cool freshen typen die die richtig
wissen was so abgeht
und ja ich möchte noch anmerken die fdp
ist ja heute nicht da aber ich werde
dann einfach ein paar mal soli
abschaffen und obergrenze innenraum
schmeißen damit es sich so anfühlt als
wäre fdp und csu auch da vielleicht ein
kleines spiel zum kennenlernen das
wollknäuel spiel ich würde jetzt ihnen
herr lindner dieses volk neu geben und
können sie den farben festhalten sie
sagen ihren namen ändern das wollknäuel
weiter zu einem beliebigen weiteren
politikern raum und wenn man jeder das
wollte nur einmal gehabt
ja ich bin eigentlich immer wenn sie das
vorhaben müssen sie etwas sagen ich bin
seit 2011 im bundestag
ich bin neu dabei sei 2017 im gespannt
ob man schon mal dahin bekommen eine
schöne insel ist es ob es nur für eine
koalition mit werden das sehen ich freue
mich auf jamaika vielleicht kommen wir
jetzt zu inhaltlichen themen
das klima cool naja das klima ist im
moment zu heiß um ehrlich zu sein und
mal lobt zu beginn zwar richtig dass die
kanzlerin in paris ein klima abkommen
unterschrieben hat da hat sich ja dazu
verpflichtet dass wir in deutschland co2
emissionen reduzieren aber die haben ja
die saubersten dieselmotoren vw also das
will man ja na ja das will man noch mal
deutlich sagen werden deutschland
produzieren die saubersten am besten
dieselmotoren in die weltweit mit
produziert werden das ist so ein
bisschen wie wenn man die waffen
herstellt die am wenigsten weh tun oder
also die saubersten dieselmotoren es ist
ja immer noch nicht sauber
das ist nicht sauber da gebe ich ihnen
recht gut
weiters gemacht flüchtlingskrise ist
eigentlich ein thema das finde ich
selber nicht geeignet um scherze darüber
zu machen es mir persönlich zu ernst
wieso stellt die csu dennoch so alberne
forderungen die ganze zeit herr müller
gut da sind keine albernen forderungen
die die csu stellt das ist realpolitik
und das ziel 200.000 menschen ab wann
ist man ein mensch ist ist man mit zwölf
schon ein fertiger mensch oder braucht
man zwei zwölfjährige was ist wenn man
drei kinder übereinander stapelt und die
in einen großen trenchcoat packt dann
eine person also für uns als cdu und csu
dann kann ich sicherlich auch für unsere
schwesterpartei sprechen als christliche
menschenbild ist jeder gleichwertig was
ist schlimmer für deutschland schwarzer
afghane oder reguläre aufgaben
hinzu von schwarzen aufgaben muss man
natürlich regulieren ich verbinde
jährige nur ein staatlich
reglementierten verkaufstellen ich habe
bereits ihre gesichter mal übereinander
gelegt in einem mord programm
und dann kommt das hier raus ist der
sogenannte visuelle humor manchmal gut
also ein kompromiss die grünen lassen
sich auch von horst seehofer
herumkommandieren und dafür übernimmt
die cdu seine pflege wir sind wer wir
würden auch aus seo von meinem wahlkreis
legen aber jetzt übrigens auch zu gast
denn wir brauchen hier keine ärzte um
horst seehofer zu pflegen sondern wir
brauchen pflege pflege ich gerne
kommandieren nicht die pflege übernimmt
die cdu also sie können ja nicht einfach
sagen also jetzt wie ich möchte mich
jetzt nicht mit den grünen streiten wie
horst seehofer schlägt ja aber ohne
quatsch wir würden horst seehofer gerne
pflegen auch in meiner heimat schon sagt
ist sagte koalitionsvertrag nur
unterschreiben ich habe mir etwas
vorbereitet herr lindner möchten sie
anfangen mit was muss ich unterschreiben
mit haustieren habe ich meine chance
ich kann natürlich für die cdu nicht
unterschreiben das kann ich mir jetzt
nicht anmaßen
wir haben da eine parteivorsitzende die
entsprechenden gremien aber ich kann es
natürlich auch bei uns groß ist es
wichtig da gibt's gräben und daran
halten wir uns also sie waren das nicht
unterschreiben
ich unterschreibe ich sehr gerne den
koalitionsvertrag sofern die inhalte
stimmen dann gibt es halt neuwahlen kann
man noch einen joint trotz drehen
es braucht jetzt her
[Applaus]